now this is really weird I'm going to
show you a picture in a second Robin but
tan mom is so tan now I'm I'm not making
a joke she literally Blends into her
brown leather couch the guy sent me this
picture I couldn't find Tam mom in the
picture
I know you think I'm exaggerating it's
like a magic wall though all right do
you see Tama oh my God yeah I'm telling
you that you're all right you should not
make her out am I sitting on the couch
yeah but when you look you only see two
people I know there you go well anyway
is she at the end of the couch and then
all of a sudden you realize
the couch has hair I say it's impressive
to him I'm your tanning ability is
amazing the the amount of sun somebody
could invade her house and if she just
sits on the couch they'll never know
she's there and what's really remarkable
about that photo is it's a screenshot of
a video so if you put it side by side
with the video you'll see like she moves
in and out of camouflage with the couch
it's it's one of the most remarkable
things I've ever seen yeah she's like
she really is yeah yeah she's like like
the Predator movie but but she she
really is at this point the leader of
the tanning Community I mean no one has
a deeper darker tan than tan mom and
nobody congratulations nobody could
dispute it I dare you
foreign